pos 俺博士を行マッサー目指して25年
好きなポケモンは
サニーゴたぜと言い皆さん何か最近というかもう昨日外から中話題になってるんです
けども
ポケモンのクイズがめっちゃ今なんか膨大になっててレアリポ行マットといえばこの
らしい
外しポケモンの知識両方がそこそこあるつ折り方思うんで
ポケモンクイックとかでも結構良いテイストれるんじゃないかと思ったねちょっと今回
はそのポケモンクイズに調整して
だと思います今回のポケモンクイズなんと出題してくれる人がいるんだぜ
この方が計画うっ
元気にするから
ああああああ
荻坂亀てよろしい
大丈夫よろしくお願います朴派とするんですよ
r 無難だねえっとしか
dj 22か
8才ですねあげたい想いだろっ
おざ俺はギリギリだなかかってこりゃー
季節用がー
の平があるの
御活躍したい一つか
ちょっと頑張りを履かねーそんな
ac も本当に4日間はいお願いします逸ノ城だけスルー
と弟子はいつもだかありがとうございました
わかりました山
水の中
すー
シャア
up to
阿部きちゃったごめん博士んですよね肌ですよね勢い余って切っちゃいました
入っていない
4世深そう2
戦前次もお願いしますありません
はい
うーんますっっ
赤線これ今回のクイズ結構初代のポケモンですねこれ
ね中学生の頃ポケモナーです
なるほど頭殴っせる記憶あるんだよなぁ
地下2階いじめられてたのは俺パンタウンかな
鬼ずねオニスズメ
あっ
シャーラー
[音楽]
脳がきっとんじゃーっ
はがれてね一挙山ちゃんだ俺えっ
ごめんは立てれば類靴などれのう
はいさん ok
好きでも滑る時の
熱が留学んじゃない
剥がせばで簡単すぎませんかイェイ
突破をとりまに応えてくれる
これはもう一番ですね嫌な感じ
図ってくれ簡単すぎるぜかじゃ子供のやったんですか
[音楽]
入っちゃったからなぁ
ちゃんとすぅーっ
次走たんだったっちゃってしいろいろ
すいませんすいませんじゃない
バッハのん
んじゃねちょっとねこのあげです
お願いします4日日本のポケモンたーーーーレバー
一番よ
んんんっ
司令と書かせこれ司令どうすればいいですか
各地区でさあ
あっていますああ
ジャイ皆さん僕これまだ1回も問題解いてないし初見なんで本気でやってますかわかり
ますかね
これなんだった
博士口悪あこりゃ分かりますねー
これは dv です
さあ
法橋意見が目立つため a
すっ私は本当に感動的だったからみんな文を覚えてるんじゃないかなぁ
あん
ポケモン欄にメってはカレーがをやっぱ感動しますよね
僕らに見ていくを見てるんですよ博士
あの滑り今度分かりますよ見ました湿地帯の
映像を打ったねーみました大江 a
アラサーカークマン
救っ全体が2分経ったをなるー
泥0あーリズムでくださっはい mn レベル寝る9分
はい僕のことは気が打ってもいいのか2いいね
ますやバーカウンターこれまず全問正解いけるよ多分赤瀬
はい
頭がを起こす時に使う道具
でしまうん
曲を得ん
が攻撃
ん落ち込ん酸っぱいはいぱーいはいはい
ポケモンの女 a
ane 車掌さあすーっ
みたいじゃめっちゃ簡単じゃないですか a これはなぁ今のキッズ買っては来ないか
なあああああ
今のキッズははかなんか初代まーすっ完備分のことを知りたかったら
11連さつらいよね専念するじゃないよ
底部のさーん
ひょっと付ときっ宣伝はまた別にします博士そう
ネス湖線も全壊したからなそれでボケをナンパになぜ
設計止めちゃってんじゃいやーて
ie
駅前ポケットモンスターミュウツーの逆襲における l 2の目的がーえーせバー衛星
読み出すこと
定番柄狩りでなぜ失って動きのんですよ進めること
3番いい増えてるそれから
うーん
んだっけなぁミュウツーの映画ですよねー
そうじゃないかなあああ
何けど見え杖が他のポケモンを操って来ませんだよな
彼が
これは全部買ったらムーン
で治して帰って講演やたせてに貼って好きなポニモってなんですか
はしますはい子が好きなポケモンは釣れないポケモンっ
頭がストカプてなかったんですけどはっはっは
これじゃんっ
そんなねっ代わってなきゃ意味ねーんだよ
んねバターカペラモデルの中で盛ってるのが
ゲシュマック多分なんですけど3番
人間たちへの復讐エージェント制度運営
r 2
カラーシャーラーしよしよしよしに損でじゃなかったこれ
これポンポン持ってるけど足がんばるぞオネエ
野球の名さーんっ
方まとめ
やったことのないポケモンわー
ネイズア
[音楽]
なるぞ
香りあー2
かねぇピカチュウは半前にサトシーの来てもなぁ
リザードもうリザードンの鍵が別れるまではサトシのポケモン
と ap はずっとかすみの腕の中にいたんで研ぎ日
しています
左手さあどうだぜ俺の力わーっ
ね散歩する
デイクレバス
[音楽]
姉あ日本ね2つスカイズ
チェンジって誰ねー
でもつかねえよな
一般人ですかさあなかった穴と別れて
仮想保持椅子は的ですよああああ
あいつかあのなんかバンダナ巻いたいいんじゃないですね
あっていたかどうかがわかる
日本その前がズっぽいんじゃないかんだけどオタクって
あそうの不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不
不
看板がきっと大歯型いいヒントくれましたねぇ
ん
てめえのな具は自由だ
せーん
ああああああ
2 o
これで君の経典をますたよ
やったぜめっちゃ簡単じゃないですか猫の呼び方じゃないか
ペットくちはあるまた次会いましょうねー
[音楽]
me
ni
えっあっ